[Music]
the second friday of ramadan and the
first day of passover did not begin
peacefully in jerusalem
those dawn prayers finished in the old
city
[Music]
israeli police went into the al-aqsa
mosque compound firing stun grenades and
tear gas
the palestinian red crescent said that
more than 150 people are injured
a field hospital was set up inside the
compound to treat them
eight policemen were also wounded
israeli police say they were reacting to
rioters who were throwing rocks at them
and jewish worshipers praying at the
adjoining western wall
the al-aqsa mosque is the third most
holy site in the islamic faith
images of smoke grenades thrown through
its windows and armed police actually
inside the mosque itself has angered the
muslim world
it was brutal
brutal reaction of the israeli police
and who brutal
[Music]
attack against prayers inside the mosque
inside the al-aqsa mosque
the standoff continued through the
morning but by lunchtime hundreds had
been arrested and it was calm again
noon prayers the main prayers on a
friday
have just finished and they were
peaceful this time in no small part
because israeli police spent the morning
arresting hundreds of people they think
were involved in the violence
jerusalem
compared to ramadan last year has been
relatively calm
that might now change
the israeli prime minister met with
senior police officers today
we are working to calm things on temple
mount and throughout israel at the same
time we are prepared for any scenario
[Music]
[Applause]
large protests took place in gaza
following friday prayers there hamas has
put its military wing on a war footing
if the group decides to launch missiles
into israel in response to what happened
in jerusalem then the chances of an
all-out conflict grow even greater still
alice debunk the sky news in jerusalem